liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger es
sind ungewöhnliche zeiten die wir
erleben ungewöhnliche und für viele
familien belastende zeiten die korona
pandemie verändert unser leben
vollkommen verändert unser zusammenleben
wir müssen abstand halten zueinander
aus verantwortung füreinander ja das ist
ein gebot der mitmenschlichkeit aber es
fällt uns oft schwer
viele menschen sitzen nun zu hause
gerade in den städten heißt das oft
allein zu hause getrennt von den leben
weit weg von der familie
andere verbringen sehr viel mehr zeit
als sonst mit dem partner der partnerin
mit der familie viele schöpfen daraus
kraft sind dankbar für die nähe für die
zeit miteinander mit den kindern aber
dieser neue alltag als familie der hat
es in sich
wer kümmert sich um die kinder wenn die
eltern als ärztin und pfleger als
busfahrer und kassiererin arbeiten wie
lassen sich home office und schule zu
hause unter einen hut bringen
die jüngste quengelt wenn der chef
anruft der zwölfjährige macht am
computer alles nur keine hausaufgaben
die mittlere hat hunger jetzt sofort und
jetzt auch noch die osterferien zu hause
und dazu kommt noch eine große sorge die
die uns besonders brauchen dürfen wir
nicht mehr sehen die einsame mutter den
gebrechlichen vater die großeltern noch
schwerer
wir dürfen sie nicht besuchen im
krankenhaus oder im pflegeheim
das reißt uns das herz entzwei und dort
gilt gerade hier halten wir abstand um
sie zu schützen halten der abstand aber
zeigen wir ihnen dass wir ihnen nahe
sind ja das fordert uns das überfordert
uns manchmal manches wächst an über den
kopf aber wir sind sicher die meisten
von ihnen verstehen dass einschränkungen
für diese zeit notwendig ja
lebensnotwendig sind und gehen damit um
und viele wachsen jetzt sogar über sich
selbst hinaus sie sind als familien
stark und das macht unsere gesellschaft
stark alles liegt mir dennoch ganz
besonders am herzen dass wir nicht die
vergessen die die krise ganz besonders
hart trifft die alleinerziehenden mütter
und väter oder die alleinstehenden deren
bedürfnis nach nähe und je eingeschränkt
ist oder die familien die auf alle
engstem raum zusammenleben und jetzt
noch größere existenz sorgen haben als
früher und die kinder die frauen für die
das eigene zuhause leider kein ort der
geborgenheit und sicherheit ist und die
jetzt viel häufiger opfer von häuslicher
gewalt zu werden drohen viele soziale
einrichtungen sind geschlossen
aber auch jetzt gibt es anlaufstellen
für menschen in not einige können sie
gleich sehen
es gibt menschen die helfen in den
jugendämtern in der kinder und
jugendhilfe in frauenhäusern über not
telefone oder ganz privat die
lebensmittel verteilen elektronisch die
hausaufgaben betreuen die
messenger-dienste und digitale
treffpunkte einrichten
ihnen allen den vielen vielen die helfen
möchten wir beide heute von ganzem
herzen danken
sie leben vor was solidarität heißt im
großen wie im kleinen
sie zeigen was unser land zusammenhält
ja wir müssen abstand halten wir sind
uns gleichzeitig nah und jeder kann
etwas tun
sie tun das schon tag für tag sie halten
zusammen füreinander für uns alle
wir sind überzeugt so bewältigen wir
diese zeit mit abstand aber gemeinsam
alles gute und geben wir acht
aufeinander